you know you've only been doing this for
a month now right and i assume that
you're planning to do this for
the foreseeable future for a while yeah
yeah for a while like is there any like
immediate goals you're looking towards
as oh gosh
tell us your five-year plan yeah
yourself where do you want to see
yourself in five years
well let's see well think about it this
way i've lived along i've lived a long
existence so you know
five years is like to me what the second
is to you so it's all good
for me basically hmm there are many
things that i have on my list
so for example um i want to release an
album
oh oh yeah full album and then i don't
know if i will ever
be able to get a 3d body it would be
nice i can't promise anything and i
don't know anything but
it would be nice if i did and at that
time i'd like to release some kind of ep
for that
all right that would be cool are you
listening whole life stuff hey guys
she wants a 3d yeah i just realized like
i don't think anyone in the en side has
had their 3d debut yet we've only been
like like we said they've only been
debuted like a month ago yeah
i always forget that i always i'm like
yeah
since the beginning
we're in this for the long run everyone
maybe that's going to be really
interesting though when that gets
debuted i think so for sure i have no
idea what even to expect but then again
i didn't for this job either so hey
looking forward to it yeah if it ever
happens
yeah cause i mean like it's it's still
[ __ ] crazy that it's just been a
month what was your opinion of youtubers
like before before you auditioned and
everything like that youtubers
yes or youtubers oh okay okay well just
or just or just like
like online content creators and
everything like that okay well i never
thought it was something i could do
because as i've mentioned before um i
wouldn't say that i'm
a shy person because i can talk well in
conversation
but i'm very much an introvert so i
don't
i don't talk to people unless they talk
to me right it's that kind of thing
i don't approach others and i like being
alone um and i get real
i get sometimes i get real sick of folks
you guys are fine you guys are funny
i just want to clarify real quick
it just it just depends it just depends
mostly in like party situations in that
case
there's a ton of people right you just
kind of want people to [ __ ] off and
leave you alone
i mean to be fair i'm like i don't mind
the occasional party area yeah but yeah
could i go to one every day no
no no exactly you get kind of tired
actually i know you can't call it i
don't know
and so i also am not um oh gosh
i've gotten used to talking but i'm not
really i'm not a being that really
enjoys
it's not that i don't enjoy it i'm bad
at talking about myself and i have a
hard time talking about myself without
getting a little flustered
i guess um so for this job i thought
wow um i feel like you have to have a
there has to be a certain level of um
not just confidence but like ability to
to talk about yourself and
well about yourself i guess so i i just
don't
i'm not sure if i knew if that was for
me or not i've been very unsure about it
um i really didn't have any streaming
experience at all i mean i've always
said that youtubers are like
like the best youtubers are always the
most narcissistic right like you have to
you have to love yourself quite a bit i
feel in order for you to be confident
enough to be on camera to be like
look at me and look how awesome well i i
would say that it is
a skill that you have you can learn
um and you i mean it's yeah but i'm
talking about like the most like
naturally talented
oh yeah hey guys hit that like and
subscribe button etc
like no one says that on their daily
life right now like anything of that
sort right like
i mean i i think you can learn
the people who can just like come
immediately onto the scene and just
look like they've been doing it for like
you know five ten years honestly i've
been doing this for ten years and
they're still
like it's still i still die inside a
little bit when i say like it's
when i say like and subscribe
yeah yeah and like i'm like i can't do
this for every video yeah exactly
exactly